có cân cạnh chứ cầu cưới hình dòng phục đuất nhất đến nhiều dất trong những ngày qua.
Đến kết từ 7,5 sò và lông vũ, phần đầu có thể cử động,
chí vì khoảng 8,5 mấy sự đồng, khoảng 18,8 tháng với sự tham gia của bú mì người.
Bây giờ nhìn thế, nhìn hôm nay làm,
lấy có rất là để có là cầu cưới hình yêu thích.
Bây giờ cũng hoai mắn, bây giờ thì ăn chí rất là hẹn sản,
rất là người mình tay chính nó ăn chí dàng hó, rất là cẹn hó,
mọi thứ, sẽ em quyết là làm như thế nào,
làm cái gì sau khi lơ đi tổ khả chịu thế này là,
thì nó cũng thích trọng phụm.
Giếm hiện tại thì trọng phụm có rất là nhiều người.
Hòa là làm rồi, cái chá, cái chí dữ thị em, em giữa vào.
Cái trong việc mà hiện tại là dễ chủ đen là,
là dữ hại sản, người em làm một cái hông gông,
nó khác là bị giả.
Là dùng mạnh bỏ sò, rừng bà ngàn cái bỏ sò để đáp tình thông ròng.
Một cái thích rất luôn, là chí dài của nó là người xáu mét.
Chí kè của nó là bố mấy trời,
con gọng nó con gói lời,
nó có thể nhi bật tính lúc, con gọng lòng nghe luôn.
thì có ngọng ở hệ trụng hết có con phía được.
Đến dưới, phủ cọc mặt lắm bố,
nó cũng thật không có mềm lấy nè.
Nếu như chụi hệ con, nó tầm khoảng 20 chí,
thì vẻ và được làm phủ cọng khoảng 2,
từ hệ gòn, đẹp dải,
ở trên đó, vậy, và nha và nha và nha và nha tải,
và nha mấy lắm dần, để kìa cùng thần.
Kìa cùng thần, thì sau là được kìa kè,
kìa, của nhà chủ luôn,
kìa cọng, ròng, ròng, phủ và và đem đơn mời chiều.